[Música]
pero no
[Aplausos]
buenos días hoy día quiero mostrarles mi
oficina esta es mi oficina acá en la
facultad donde realizó la planificación
de mis clases donde hago investigación
donde me reúno con estudiantes y
ayudantes que trabajan conmigo fuera de
la sala de clases pero también quiero
mostrarles esta otra oficina que es mi
otra oficina del lado de terapeuta en
esta en ambas oficinas el trabajo es muy
similar de hecho mucho más similar de lo
que yo hubiese pensado hace algunos años
atrás el objetivo principal en cada uno
de estos lugares es entregarles
herramientas a pacientes y a estudiantes
para el desarrollo personal y
profesional
una de las problemáticas principales de
mis pacientes o consultantes es la
frustración que muchas veces llevan por
no poder hacer lo que ellos quisieran
por no poder poner en el otro la idea
que tienen o que no les haga caso que
traten de cambiar que tienen las mejores
intenciones para hacer las cosas a su
modo pero no resulta una de las
principales preguntas de los estudiantes
cuando aprenden una herramienta nueva o
un concepto nuevo que les les da mucho
sentido dicen cómo lo hago para poder
aplicarlo en mi equipo de trabajo cómo
hago para que el resto os vea las cosas
como yo las veo aquí la respuesta que yo
doy en ambas oficinas es la misma y
acepta es el mundo
vamos a suponer por un par de minutos
que todos los que estamos aquí somos
extraterrestres
y nos han pedido que podamos describir
el planeta tierra para otros
extraterrestres que hoy día no pudieron
venir acá entonces nosotros miramos este
planeta tierra desde aquí que estamos
acá enfrente y tenemos que describirlo
tenemos que dar nuestro informe y
decimos bueno el planeta tierra es una
esfera muy grande que tiene una masa de
tierra en la parte superior luego casi
se corta en la parte central lo que era
unida por un hilo muy muy pequeño y
luego se ensancha nuevamente hacia abajo
y se hacen angosto reduce nuevamente
hacia abajo ya está rodeada por algunas
masas de agua principalmente una masa de
agua importante se aprecia en el sector
izquierdo inferior y ese es nuestro
informe
pero tenemos un amigo que está por allá
y también le han pedido este informe y
el amigo hace el informe entonces veamos
qué informe entrega este extraterrestre
él dice
el planeta tierra es una gran esfera
donde existe una gran masa de tierra en
el sector superior y centro en el centro
eso es muy ancho y luego se achica un
poco y se pone más angosto hacia abajo y
tiene está rodeado por algunas masas de
agua
es ese informe tenemos otro amigo
extraterrestre que está allá en el otro
lado y también hace su informe veamos el
informe de este amigo
y dice
el planeta tierra es una esfera muy
grande que tiene una masa en el centro
inferior de tierra no muy grande pero
que está rodeada por una gran cantidad
de agua y la agrega en su informe en
efecto creo que no se debería llamar
planeta tierra sino que se debería
llamar planeta agua
nosotros enviamos estos tres informes a
los extraterrestres que no vinieron hoy
día y no entienden cómo es este planeta
tierra porque unos le dicen una cosa
otras le dicen otra entonces nos dicen
saben que pónganse de acuerdo entre los
tres y nos dicen cómo es el planeta y
nosotros estamos en eso cada uno desde
su lado tratando de ponernos de acuerdo
y de determinar quién tiene la razón y
quién tiene la razón acá
ninguno todos todos tienen la razón
todos tienen la razón desde su propio
punto de vista todos tienen la razón
desde el punto donde ellos están parados
en este sentido es importante entender
que la única forma en la cual nosotros
nos podemos poner de acuerdo es entender
que las distintas miradas son las que
componen la realidad completa la
totalidad de la realidad si nosotros no
consideramos la verdad y la visión la
mirada de cada uno nunca vamos a poder
entender el todo tenemos que considerar
la mirada a la realidad de cada una de
las partes sin exclusión e incluso con
la misma relevancia
entonces cuando ponemos esto decimos
bueno por qué es tan difícil ponerse de
acuerdo o obtener puntos de vista
distinto y es la respuesta que yo le doy
a estos pacientes o consultante ya los
estudiantes claro te estás poniendo en
el punto de vista de uno de ellos pero
no estás viendo el resto es que no es
que el otro no tenga la razón
el otro tiene su propia razón porque
tiene su propio punto de vista porque
depende del lugar en el que nos situemos
cada uno de nosotros lo que vamos a
opinar lo que vamos a pensar lo que nos
va a dar miedo lo que nos va a gustar lo
que vamos a accionar y desde la realidad
convencida de lo más absoluto de nuestro
corazón porque es lo que nosotros vemos
y tenemos certeza de ello este lugar
desde el cual nosotros accionamos y
actuamos en el día a día depende de
donde nacimos depende de nuestra familia
de nuestra cultura de nuestras
costumbres de la educación que hemos
tenido
de nuestros amigos depende de las
experiencias de vida que nosotros hemos
pasado
entonces es difícil porque tenemos que
respetarlas todas como válidas no sé si
nosotros pudiéramos reconocer estos
aspectos distintos de cada situación y
valorarlos adecuadamente nosotros
podríamos solucionar tantos problemas en
el mundo estos problemas que nos afectan
a todos en el mundo problemas
relacionados por ejemplo con los
recursos naturales problemas de la
contaminación problemas de pobreza si
nosotros nos pusiéramos cada uno desde
su punto de vista podríamos solucionar
estos problemas de manera holística sin
embargo en el mundo no somos capaces de
ver lo de nuevas barreras físicas
barreras idiomáticas culturales
políticas religiosas económicas que nos
impiden ponernos de acuerdo
si nos hemos puesto de acuerdo por
ejemplo en cuáles son estas
problemáticas y a través de la
definición de los 17 objetivos del
desarrollo sostenible
nos hemos logrado poner de acuerdo de
cuáles son los problemas pero en
términos de cómo los vamos a solucionar
no existen tantas diferencias que nos es
imposible poder hacerlo
dado que no podemos ponernos de acuerdo
a nivel global porque tenemos tantas
diferencias bueno pensemos entonces en
si nos podemos poner nos podríamos poner
de acuerdo como país
entonces tenemos problemáticas que nos
afectan a todos como país porque la
salud por ejemplo es un tema importante
en el norte en el centro en el sur la
contaminación no es un tema solamente de
la región metropolitana es un tema del
norte del sur es un tema de cordillera
incluso hasta el mar entonces porque no
somos capaces y porque no nos desafiamos
a abordar estas problemáticas como país
desde las distintas posiciones en que
estamos nosotros es que no nos va muy
bien y no nos va muy bien porque
nuevamente tenemos diferencias políticas
económicas de poder de no querer sever
cada uno
asegura que tiene su realidad y que esa
es la valía y que del otro no entonces
no nos pueden poner de acuerdo
esto también sucede incluso dentro de
las organizaciones cuando nosotros vemos
una organización o una empresa también
sucede un amo dirían ok son son más
pequeños por lo tanto ahí se está
coordinado y hacemos todos lo mismo no
imagínense ustedes lo que opinan es una
organización del área de marketing es
que esto de marketing gastan muchos
y marketing dice que ellos invierten
para desarrollar la relación con el
cliente después que dicen de finanzas no
es que el área finanza son súper
restrictivos no nos sueltan nada y
finanza que dice de sí mismo es que yo
optimiza los recursos de la organización
y que dice la organización muchas veces
de recursos humanos es que hace algunas
cosas que a lo mejor no son tan
relevantes y recursos humanos
a su vez piensa que son un aliado
estratégico de la organización entonces
incluso vemos que dentro de la
organización
cada uno tiene mirada distinta y
desprecia muchas veces inclusive los
objetivos y las miradas del otro
entonces tampoco lo podemos lograr a
nivel de organización
nos preguntamos con un grupo de
profesores
si podíamos levantar estas visiones
distintas con nuestros alumnos a través
de la universidad y esto es un desafío
importante porque no estamos tan
alejados como los países del mundo
tampoco como en chile en su geografía
pero sí tenemos campos que están
bastante alejados no tenemos un campus
único entonces esto también implicaba
alguna barrera física en este desarrollo
pero nuestro objetivo era hacer ver y
valorar la visión ampliada nuestro
objetivo era tratar de entregar a
nuestros estudiantes esta visión de
recoger las distintas miradas de las
disciplinas de las distintas facultades
de nuestra universidad para poder
resolver problemas que eran problemas
comunes entonces lo que buscamos con
este equipo de profesores fue integrar
los intereses y las capacidades de los
estudiantes que teníamos
para poder llevar a cabo proyectos con
miradas interdisciplinarias para poder
tomar la creatividad académica para
poder tomar la investigación científica
de tal forma que pudieran ver luz en
proyectos concretos
lo que hicimos fue
un curso que se inició este año donde
tuvimos 96 estudiantes inscritos de 30
carreras distintas que desarrollaron 15
proyectos durante todo el semestre la
metodología que nosotros aplicamos fue
una metodología de design thinking donde
se establecían como objetivos que los
proyectos estuvieran orientados a
algunos de los desafíos o de ese sea que
atendieran asuntos sociales comunes y
que tuvieran una propuesta concreta de
solución
tuvimos un bootcamp un bootcamp que
combinamos con metodología blended
utilizando clases en módulos grabados y
presentaciones físicas de de los avances
donde nos juntábamos para hacer tutorías
también con los con los estudiantes
todos los equipos eran
interdisciplinarios por lo tanto
teníamos 30 carreras diversas en cada
uno de estos de estos equipos la verdad
es que el resultado de todo esto fue
espectacular
tuvimos 15 proyectos buenísimos por
descarte de destacar solamente algunos
algunos de ellos esta es la es la feria
que hicimos el proyecto de the smart
water y ellos analizaba la problemática
de sequía y desarrollaron el riego a
través del uso tecnificado de micorrizas
con goteo solar para regadíos agrícolas
y antes utilizaron el conocimiento que
tenían en su facultad y en su en su
disciplina para poder llevarlo adelante
el proyecto lilia una plataforma que
buscaba entregar información veraz y
soporte a quienes por identidad de
género se sentían discriminados
principalmente en servicios de salud y
en otras instituciones el proyecto de
algas que busca una solución energética
a través de biocombustible para las
empresas en base a algas modificadas con
alta eficiencia y bajo costo y así
tuvimos 12 proyectos más que éstos
la característica principal de estos
proyectos era el enfoque holístico de
las soluciones tuvimos como resultado
estudiantes motivados que valoraron y
respetaron el trabajo interdisciplinario
y eso fue muy enriquecedor verlo estas
fueron algunas de las palabras con que
los estudiantes describieron su
experiencia que había un trabajo
colaborativo más allá del trabajo en
equipo y la solidaridad que eso fue
bastante transversal la calidad humana
que pudieron encontrar en otra en otros
estudiantes la empatía el efecto de
crear de estrechar lazos de crear redes
ahora conocen gente en distintas
facultades y algo que quiero destacar
algunos comentarios específicos que
fueron dijeron se expandieron los
horizontes de mis propios pensamientos
ahora puedo pensar más allá de lo que yo
creía que existía
entender que existen miradas distintas y
complementarias vuelvo al ejemplo
inicial ya estamos logrando que ellos
tengan esta visión integral potenciar
además las capacidades en las cuales
ellos son buenos y algo muy
significativo darse cuenta que no se la
sabían todas y que habían otros que
también podrían aportar en sus saberes y
en sus capacidades
estamos muy contentos de este resultado
que tuvimos probablemente nosotros no
vamos a poder cambiar el mundo es muy
difícil hacer que el mundo tenga estas
distintas miradas probablemente va a ser
difícil que podamos también lograr esta
está trabajo conjunto a lo largo de
nuestro país en alguna instancia pero
también con dificultades podemos
lograrlo a nivel de una organización o
empresa si es que intervenimos pero si
no pudimos lograr en este curso este
curso lo que podemos lograr en nuestros
estudiantes estas visiones holística
estas visiones integrativas y por lo
tanto a través de nuestros egresados
nosotros vamos a poder cambiar las áreas
donde ellos ellos se desempeñan ellos
son motores de cambio donde a futuro
vayan a desempeñar sus labores y este
motor de cambio no solamente va a mover
a las organizaciones donde van
puede mover al país y quien no sabe si
también va a mover al mundo muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]